what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 10th of january from the
heart of [__] new jersey and
the heart of new jersey the joint is
brought to you by draftkings as you know
the nfl playoffs are here and draftking
sportsbook as an official sports betting
partner of the nfl is kicking things off
with a [__] tremendous offer here we
go you ready come down to the super bowl
56 new customers can get 56 to one odds
on any wild card team to win their game
did you hear what the [__] i said to you
just spent five dollars to win
280 and free [__] bets if your team
wins now if sportsbook isn't available
in your state yet you still got
something to play for this wild card
weekend everyone can play for huge cash
prizes with draftkings daily fantasies
football contest draftkings is giving
all new customers a free shot at
millions of [__] dollars i know you
[__] play fantasy and this is
the time to [__] do it
in total prizes with your first deposit
download the draftkings sportsbook app
today or the fantasy app use promo code
joey do not forget there's a great
[__] game tonight the national
championship georgia against alabama
listen this is going to be a [__]
brown burner go to [__]
draftkings download the sports kit app
and bet one of those teams they're going
to have props you can make some money on
a [__] monday you understand me and
don't forget the nfl that we're doing on
draftkings 56 to one odds you bet five
dollars to win 280 and free bets if your
team wins that's promo code joey this
wildcat week at draftkings sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl check yourself [__] you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana pa
west virginia colorado new customers
only i'm hooking you up [__]
minimum five dollar deposit and one
dollar wage and remember one per
customer don't be [__] greedy
restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportbook for details now
if you got a gaming problem i want you
to take care of it it's 1-800 gamble but
if not head over to draftkings download
the draftking sports book app or the
fantasy app and win some [__]
adidas that's how we're doing here we're
starting a year off with a bang if you
didn't get your dick sucked i'm showing
up with [__] draftkings ba-boom hey
the joint is also brought to you by c b
d line i started my little cbd
regimen again i started my [__] alpha
brain for the year that's what it was i
think i needed some [__] alpha brain
black label they're not [__] around
but anyway we're talking about c b d
lion the extra strength unscented cbd
the [__] tincture the back ball the
kinesiology tape they have little piece
of kinesiology tape that you can just
get put on your shoulder listen
if you need it cbd line got it go to
cbdline.com right now take a look at
that third party lab results and get
something from the cream they got
[__] gel caps that you pop listen
you're gonna need it's gonna be a cold
winter everybody's stressing out on
different things a little cbd will calm
you down go to cbd line pressing joey
your joint and get 20 off delivered to
your [__] crib that cbd lion
let's get this party started it's monday
morning we're kicking out the
[__] jams brothers and sisters
[Music]
welcome to uncle joy's joy
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 10th of january last
week was a [__] week it was a write-off
you know
people's heads were in their ass it was
snowing the numbers were high you were
waiting online for covert test your
results thank god the hoop landed it's
the [__] tenth it's the first full
week of the year and we're going
straight [__] ahead it was a great
weekend
i'm feeling great i'm looking great i'm
tip top [__] magoo my balls
smell great i'm back [__] it's a new
year with a new [__] attitude
i'm sorry about the podcast last week
they were a little off you know i was a
little off from the [__] covered mind
i have no [__] idea what was going on
with me last week guys so uh
i have an idea i ran out of medication i
was getting bad headaches i thought it
was the covert i thought it was the
[__] medication i thought it was the
vapor pen yeah so i had to start slicing
this [__] off my headaches went away and
uh
i'm ready for 2022
regardless of what the [__] gonna
happen with this or that it's got
nothing to do with us
uh today i do have a [__] guest i've
been
really waiting for this guy
we uh i'll tell you the story in 19
[__] 90 october 1990 i got separated
by december january i had lost my job
with my family the roofing company and
the whole you know shebang
i i had nothing going on i was doing
some comedy i started coming in 91 we
was yeah we got separated i'm sorry in
october of 91.
and
you know i had no family i really had
nothing i lost my job but when i got out
of prison i was in the halfway house and
i got a job at a place called the puddle
car wash in boulder tremendous
they had hired me when i first moved to
boulder that uh december of 86 they
hired me to dry off cars
that [__] bill's character jack you're
out there with two [__] towels in
boulder colorado there's a line around
the [__] block and you gotta dry off
[__] cars and you know the people
give you tips and you steal one when
they're not looking there's a little box
in you but it was a great job you got
tips at the end of the day you know you
got like 40 bucks and tips there's 20
gorillas out there the guy was great bob
the owner
by now he's probably [__] on to the
next level of life he punched the ticket
his wife was great i worked there with a
black dude he was a tremendous football
player at cu named howard
my boss there his name is richie [__]
great people man and uh
i worked there for about uh six weeks
the first time from uh december to like
mid-january and then i got a job at
boulder auto body that's where i met
[__] tidwell and then the plan of the
kidnapping came along but we'll get to
that later
and uh
it was you know i was lost but when i
worked at this when i got out of the
halfway house i i needed a job
i had knocked up my ex-wife i needed
something that made money and one day
rich great guy from new york called me
and he goes listen
i got a position for you you're gonna
make some money you work three days a
week you probably walk out here with a
grand a week you know that's great money
and sometimes there's saturday sometimes
there's overtime blah blah blah
and it's just great you're outside
you're talking to people and i i took
the job i had to you know and i
it was a great [__] job you stood
outside with a [__] pad
people pull up they ask you for the
special and you got to try to upsell you
know rims
undercarriage armor all [__] you know
this car sent
it was great and i got to meet a lot of
[__] people i got to meet like
boulder undercover cops because the
sheriff's department
would wash their cars there so now i
knew all the undercovers from boulder
county sheriff's office
i ended up meeting bill wise there if
you look up bill wise he was with the
d.a
and boulder when uh
what's the [__] name the little kid
john bernay ramsey he was part of that
thing i met a bunch of those cops the
chick that did the the reason why they
couldn't prosecute the ramsey she was a
lesbian cop great lady
great lady she was like a [__]
sergeant she's probably like a captain
now
i think i saw on tv a couple years ago i
know her
and uh she uh
she no she's a great lady
she went into the [__]
uh
john jonbenet house and
did a [__] circle prayer you know so
they [__] up the evidence so they
couldn't really do nothing
barry scheck was on fire from the oj
trial with the dna [__] so she
anyway but one of the best
people i also met the feebles in there
the other cuban family in boulder
i met uh the wrestler whatever his
[__] name was that oh my god uh the
ultimate [__] whatever his name the
ultimate warrior was there once without
his makeup on i recognized him he was
[__] yoked it was just a great you
know how it is it was 91
i was 28 years old 29 years old you know
and i'm outside [__] making dough
i was a big shot i was in the halfway
house you know i had to hide money i
made tips you know because i cut deals
with people
but uh one of the best guys i met in
there was i i would sit there all day
and guys would come in to wash their
cars and these as one group of guys were
coming all the time
new yorkers all from long island [__]
heavy duty guys acuras you know [__]
uh 280z's these guys all had great cars
and they looked like they were making a
great living and we talked and they were
they'd always come in just to talk to me
to hear the new york accent they'd say
we love going down there so when they
asked him i go dog what do you [__]
guys do that you drive all these cars
and [__] and they go we're in the sports
business so i thought it was a sports
betting business i didn't know what the
[__] it was and i'm like guys if you
ever need somebody i tortured these guys
for about a year then i moved on i quit
the job
i focused on comedy whatever i was you
know i was just [__] around i was
divorced so what else did i have going
on
and one day like in july
one of those guys
text me you know text me paged me i was
the pager man like in the wire it was
all pages and [__]
and i started watching that show again
brilliant have you ever seen the why
it's time you watch it again i'm up to
episode eight and we're going straight
to episode 64. but anyway
uh this guy richie came in there was a
guy rizzo and there was a guy george and
they would always come in and one day
finally
they contacted him and they go do you
want a job where we work before you go
for the job it's seven days a week
you work august 15th to super bowl
no weekends you work
every [__] day you work the only day
you have off is wednesday and that's if
you're lazy most of the people came in
that was the work ethic they expected
from you they were [__] heavy-duty
new yorkers
so i told rich i go yeah you know set up
an interview i went there i talked to
the guy they all interviewed me a week
later they called they said you got the
job coming august 15 for training
it was [__] unreal like to be around
new yorkers all day i went in there for
training they would cater the [__]
training sessions great food sandwiches
i'm flat broke i'm doing comedy i went
in there for that was how i ate
breakfast like i was the first guy there
because they had bagels they would get
bagels shipped in from [__] new york
on sundays these if you worked on the
weekends these guys took care of you
like there was food there
you know it was just great pizzas they
did everything they did they really
tried but
they trained you for two weeks they
really sat with you
and worked thoroughly with you and it
was just a standard pitch i don't know
if any of you guys have ever sold
anything on the phone or anything
it was just a standard pitch you know uh
and but
you were always closing like i didn't
know i thought i was a [__] salesman
i had sold cars and [__] like that i
thought i knew what i was doing i knew
nothing
i had read a book telemarketing in the
80s
before i got that job you could throw
that book out the [__] window great
book it applied to me for different
areas and stuff like that but
these guys taught me how to [__] sell
objections you know right now i'm taking
jiu-jitsu and i'm doing core program
that means you do like cybertel uh
drills you break the guard you know they
teach you [__] it's basically nice and
light until you get to the blue belt
program and it's exactly what i need i'm
an old man i want to get my strength for
maybe 90 days just going and drill drill
drill drill what i've noticed about
drilling is
that now when somebody touches me with
something i go right for an armbar i go
for a camara it's a great way to teach
somebody and that's the same way
these guys worked with you it was
[__] thorough and then for a week you
just call people with them listening
and it was hilarious like they would
come up to you and tell you what to
[__] say
sometimes they'd pick up the phone while
you were talking to somebody and talk to
that person like if it was you and the
person on the other side didn't know i
had learned stuff
that was blowing my [__] mind like
every time i leave there but i had a
problem
my cocaine addiction was on [__] fire
like i was on fire that i had a single i
was single i had a basement apartment in
north hollywood i could walk to the
[__] job it was on like iris [__]
office was great we were in a mall with
abel's pizza ledizio murphy's bar and
grill a barber shop place underneath i
mean guys it was a dream come true
i had i was i couldn't give it all my
attention because of comedy
and because of what i was going through
with the separation and divorce
the first year i did i did okay you know
they said that the first year you're
gonna have your humps and your bumps you
learn rejection
but you grind it brother you [__]
grind it and
if you listen
to what they said to you you wouldn't
make money
once you started doing what you wanted
you're not gonna make fun of money but
you had to be very aggressive
you know it's like uh
you had to sell sports
information and yeah we won we won a lot
but
there's a week you know when you have
you have the ups and you know ups and
downs and anything especially [__]
gambling
i was always involved with gambling
because of my family
but i had learned a complete different
[__]
world of gambling and how they
approached it they analyzed the gambler
psychologically these guys had put a lot
of money into what they did they knew
what they were doing
but what they taught me was to [__]
always be selling
and be aggressive i was always kind of
aggressive not with my sales because i
don't like to for sales people to be
aggressive with me
but for this particular job you're
working with [__] gamblers and it's a
different
psychology and they had tapped into it
these guys from long island
this guy's stu flying he's no [__]
yale graduate but he's got balls of
steel
and a mine to make [__] dough and
anyway i did three years with them you
know i did uh 93
the first year they [__] fired me
because of my cocaine problem i would
just go in there with a napkin in my
nose and i was all [__] clogged up
all the time you can't sell when you're
clogged up then he gave me a second
chance he's a great guy those guys let
me tell you what they would do man i
would work six months
whatever money you put away they'd match
it
and they'd break it up into the six
months you were gonna be off and every
month you got a check
that's what i didn't tell you when i
told you i was delivering chinese food i
would deliver chinese food do comedy
and get a check from them and that would
pay my rent my child support that's how
much they took care of their [__]
people
this was a
tremendous company
i had a great opportunity with them i
[__] blew it
but it brought me back after i got the
voice i was lost
this brought me back i was around guys
every day talking about [__] yelling at
people [__] you grab your [__] credit
card we called my room the voodoo lounge
because they had like different rooms
and we had like a [__] crazy room in
the back what they called the voodoo
lounge we'd be eating yelling they had
girls in that i'd give you the paperwork
college girls it was just a a great time
you know and then
january of 95 my plan was to work till
uh january of 95 and then i was trying
to get on the road you know at that time
i was doing like [__] one-nighters and
stuff but i was working you know not
every [__] day
and i never forget um
the big like i had never worked a full
week like i had never worked the full
week i always worked like saturday or
tuesday
so after you become an open mic and you
get up a little bit like 20 minutes you
call a guy if you're on the west coast
you call a guy named david tribble
if you're a comic you know what that
name is david tribble books the pacific
northwest
and it's triple runs triple runs is how
you learn how to do comedy it's hand to
hand comedy you don't know what's going
to happen till you get there when you
get to the the manager gives you a
[__] piece of paper
and it says this room is active if
somebody throws a bottle at you
call the management and go to your room
you know this is this type of comedy but
i was ready for it and i'll never forget
that one night while i was at
work at the
sports betting service
they called me and they said we we have
a fallout in boulder
the triple run if you could do it
tonight
tribbles wants to see a report and if
everything pans out you're on the road
with triple i was in [__] shocked i'm
like i made it
so i told the guys and we all went down
it was a tuesday night boulder broke it
was on tuesday nights by that time i'd
been fired i was the house emcee for
about a year there by that time i had
been fired they i had to get special
permission to go back and do comedy they
welcomed me like yeah come back oh my
god you're the feature oh my god this is
phenomenal i forget who the headliner
was but i went down there all the guys
from the office came that was the
camaraderie you had like for the first
time in years i was fine
these guys came cheered they bought food
we drank it was [__] tremendous
i ended up getting like i did great and
next thing you know the guy called me
and said you're on the road
and it was rough to quit that [__]
job but it was time for me to do comedy
and it was also time for me by that time
i knew that i wasn't going to do
anything in boulder but
the three football seasons i worked at
what stu finer and his staff taught me
was invaluable
invaluable i learned about people
i learned that people always [__]
you i learned the mind of the gambler
but most importantly i learned how to
sell from the [__] balls and that
came in
seven years later because you could be
the best comic in the world but if you
don't know how to sell your [__]
product you got dick you know how many
what are you gonna call people and say
i'm funny
sell your [__] product [__] something
this guy taught me how to sell
i recently moved to jersey and uh jimmy
florentine works for bar stool sports
and one day i saw that
stu finder was on there so i got
emotional you know i was like wow
[__] stew still at it i know stu in
he was in it already 10 [__] years
probably since he was like 10 10 this
[__] is aggressive as [__]
and here we are 2021
and stu is still there yelling [__]
believing in himself and for a guy like
me doug that's [__] inspiring that's
inspiring he tells a great story and i
hope you [__] enjoy it
thank you enjoy [__] mr stew
[__] fighter jack
[Music]
uncle stew
joey what's doing brother welcome to the
joint my man how are you uh it's an
honor ready to roll so excited i am so
happy to see you i
you know i asked around i didn't know
what was going on
i talked to some of the boys from the
sports advisors from time to time they
come to the shows
i don't even know you in the business at
all anymore wow i moved to new york i
put on i see you on twitter i follow you
and you're [__] great i've been
following you retweeting the games for
the week
you are a [__]
professional man
everything's good you know it's all i've
ever done so in other words uh and now
with the internet and now with a new
audience of young people you know i'm
just as [__] crazy as ever i mean the
energy is ever you know uh is is bigger
than ever i take a t shot every two
weeks and uh that just gives me
unlimited [__] energy you know live
on caffeine right now caffeine in a tee
shot and uh i'm ready to go i mean i'm
only sleeping like four hours a night
and loving life you know i got you know
i got four uh men that live with me my
kids 32 30 26 22 and three of the four
live with me and total insanity
everybody's partying every day drinking
every day you know getting [__] up and
uh you know it's a great life you've
worked some great [__] life you know
broken 50 blunts a day nine cups of
starbucks coffee
how the [__] do you do this i'm cuban
i was doing eight shots of espresso in
l.a
nice four at night four before i went to
the comedy store oh i love it i love it
here and i stopped drinking espresso
like i just drink one cup of coffee now
and and that does it for you huh that
does it throughout the day i gotta drink
a coke zero for caffeine purposes right
the headache away
but beside that man you look great
i love that you put pictures of your dad
he's your [__] twin
so what has happened in 30 years
um well i mean basically you know i went
uh almost broke three times and uh now i
get the world by the bulls i'm printing
money i got i got [__] in my backyard
i got five [__] trees hundred dollar
bills on the trees when you come here
when we get [__] up i'm gonna let you
pick hundred dollar bills you leave with
five ten grand everybody's happy ready
to roll oh my god
you are insane i mean everything
every day is insane you know even even
with the culvert we got you know
anywhere between 10 to 40 people a day
running around my backyard um the house
that i've been living in since 1990
that's still what i have uh i work i
worked as a landscaper when i was a kid
in seventh grade joe and um
on a 7.8 acre estate it was the william
schwindler estate and he was the
co-founder of grumman aerospace with
leroy grumman and in uh world war ii
in the 40s vice presidents used to be in
my basement because they were talking
about you know how the [__] they could
bomb germany and [__] bomb japan and
win the [__] war god god willing um
william schwindler's claim to fame was
the movie apollo 13 uh with tom hanks
and gary sinise well in that movie
there's a scene where they have two
tables and they throw all the [__] on
the tables and they said to the
scientists we got to get them down and
the owner of this house william
schwindler got them down and that was
his claim to thing they landed at
laguardia airport
drove right to hicksville where grumman
aerospace is and i'm about two minutes
away from there so it was a 7.8 acre
estate and oddly enough in seventh grade
i said
um mr schwindler mr schwindler
when you sell this house i would like to
buy it and they looked at me with like
two heads they're like what's this
[__] jew talking about hey buddy you
know go wipe your butt you say you're
you're [__] 14 by the grace of god
you know i scored out in the 80s uh with
my sports advisor service and with 900
numbers and when they died it was in the
will for them to call me they called me
in 1989. they wanted at the time 2.2
million negotiated for six months and i
paid 1.4 million the 7.8 acres it's a uh
a 1.8 acre side field uh 2.5 acres with
the house is on and then 3.2 acres in
the back the house at the time was 1900
square feet
1936 english tudor and then when i
bought it i put 800 grand into the house
200 000 into the pool made it 4 300
square feet matched the brick and the
slate roof from a burnt down school in
massachusetts and i've been kicking
[__] ass since in 1994 i paid um 4.8
million dollars for a score phone
operation in atlanta georgia where um
they were getting 48 million calls a
year on 200 score phones and at the time
before the internet before you could get
scores on your phone before all these
channels on tv gate scores we gave
scores odds lines injury weather reports
and then we inundated it with ads um i
sold the back field in my backyard to a
builder together we built 11 houses and
we named it after my oldest son it's
called sean michael court um i sold a
1.8 acre side field right next to me and
then i kept the 2.5 acres bought the
score phone um paid 4.8 million put 800
000 down had a note for 1.2 million per
year we wrote 10
million
in four years world by the bulls
business was evaluated at 30 million ps
this is nuts joe you this is [__]
crazy it's like murphy's law my last
payment
to the owner
paid it me and sandy go to france party
our [__] balls off come back
and cbs sportsline opened their website
i went in six months 48 million calls
4.8 million calls 480 000 calls 48 000
calls
at a [__] business
and then i had to get into other areas
so i got like professional athletes uh
to work for me ex coaches ex players and
i promoted them
and then that didn't work and then
anthony almost put me out of business
and i floundered probably from 1999
2000 to 2010 on the balls of my ass i
couldn't afford water for my kids and i
just grinded grinded i beg boarded and
stealed borrowed money from everybody i
ever [__] met borrowed money from the
mafia didn't pay my taxes i dug a seven
million dollar hole because
i didn't want to lose my life and my
lifestyle i was advised go out of
business bankrupt yourself wipe it out
and start again i'm like well a can't
beat the mafia out of money because
don't put a gun in my head my my mouth
and kill me b
government ain't going away and see i
can't [__] friends my sister-in-law lent
me money every friend i ever met p.s
by 2018
i paid every [__] penny back seven
million [__] dollars
and then by the grace of god dave
portnoy who owns barstool sports called
me and said stu
me and my father used to watch you in
the 90s on the sports advisors we
[__] love you we don't like you we
love you we want to bring back your
sports advisors show re-branded barstool
sports devices and then um in 2006 they
use my tv show in the movie two for the
money
al pacino played me renee russo played
my wife matthew mcconaughey in real life
played a disgruntled employee that
worked for me and in that movie al
pacino
md
yeah exactly al pacino matthew
mcconaughey and jeremy pippen were on my
tv show so basically now i'm like the
hottest [__] thing in the world i'm i
mean i'm not as hot as you i'm not as
good-looking as you but i'm [__] hot
as [__] just like you said the other day
you go to a carville your mom i can't go
anywhere without people and by the grace
of god listen if i was [__] my wife
and someone wanted to take a picture i
would tell my wife honey hold on and
i'll take the picture because this is
like this is like living a a storybook
life can't get enough of it i went to
these islander games during every period
there was a line of 100 people to take
pictures with me where the [__] am i
five four and three quarters if i was
200 sure i'd be perfectly round i'm a
[__] nobody i got [__] 940 on my
sats i'm half a [__] idiot but by the
grace of god i'm living a life that i've
never dreamed before and you know it's
only going to get bigger i'm getting
bigger and bigger every year i just you
know i sell merchandise i do an amazing
job with shout outs so what i do is i
stand on my [__] diving board and i
read shout outs i read people's fantasy
football lineups and i'm doing hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year in shout
outs it's like my new business it's like
if i lose my voice i'm like it's in a
[__] kill me i'll commit suicide but
until my voice goes you know i got a
license to make a million dollars a year
it's [__] amazing
you know stu these
the youth of america a lot of people
really do not understand
what you did
from scratch
i know the other guy's story their first
year
in the basement with ma
you know the two brothers but your story
is so superb but i'm going to tell you
something
the reason why x i excelled in comedy
years later
was because of what you taught me on
those [__] phones
thank you how [__] crazy is that
thank you i remember going to seattle
and out working everybody and one of the
guys came up to me like what are you a
[__] new yorker you came here and
took everybody's work what the [__] and
i go no i worked harder than you i got
on the phone on mondays
and the same pitch the same way voracity
you guys taught me you know go for the
card what's the card number five you
know start
[__] whatever capital one i mean it
was just
you i didn't know while i was doing it
what i was learning
and i pitched shows with that knowledge
i went in
i took so much from that job that came
back to me later i want these people to
know the the [__]
the size of what you were doing from
nothing
yeah i mean in basement yeah and and
thank you very much for saying that
that's quite kind and be honest with you
you cannot believe how many people have
called me and said stu i worked because
i've had pretty much like i'd say over
5000 people work for me from 1980 until
now and people have said stu your
training prepared me for life at any
interview i did i was heads and tails i
was the general manager in six months
because you know what i did i taught
people that confidence is everything
confidence flows through your body
through the phone
through individuals even in person and
you control the conversation if you
remember my training notes it was listen
listen listen do this do this do this
fair enough fair enough fair enough
what's that mastercard number five one
five one five one what's the visa number
four one four one listen listen listen
and you never let the customer talk
they bought you and they bought your
enthusiasm and that's basically if you
can have that
skill set in life
world your oyster as you said you
outwork people because you knew what it
was listen my people like me i work from
1982 to 1997. i work seven days a week
24 hours a day i miss people's weddings
i miss bar mitzvahs i miss birthdays
because i said hey listen i'm [__]
working here that's the bottom line and
in other words it really you know like
for example i love you i really love you
because it makes me feel so good that
because i broke my [__] balls and you
know a lot of people
when they were killing they were on
their own and basically you know robbed
me and [__] me and made their money on
their own and then they never thanked me
but there are people that did thank me
like you said like i taught you a skill
set that was valuable in all areas of
life doesn't matter what you could have
done you could have been a lawyer you
could have been a politician and you
chose to be a comedian and a comedian
really commands the room
people are desperate to laugh because as
you know as i know we were on the balls
of our [__] ass we were this close to
[__] dying or wishing we were dead
you know we tried to kill ourselves we
couldn't wish and we were dead and in
other words most people's lives suck as
you know they suck dick so they're
looking for someone just to lift them up
because most people are extremely
insecure feel extremely inadequate and
my job always was entertainment if i can
entertain you if i can make you happy
that's my goal in life that's my [__]
goal in life and i gave the world to
everyone like i had a ton of secrets and
i gave them to everybody off the bat i
wasn't smart then because i probably
should have held a little back because
once i torch everything you know
actually i gave you the keys to the
kingdom but i was okay with that i
really was i feel humble i feel grateful
and i feel blessed and that's that's
really how i roll you know every day i
wake up i'm on my [__] knees and my
day starts with this exact prayer since
probably 1985 i say please god
give me the strength to be abstinent
from my compulsive overeating my
gambling my drug addiction my sexual
behavior my abuse of language my
compulsive spending of my selfishness
you know please
lift my difficulties and my character
defects so i can bet a person one day at
a time and that's really how i roll you
know i fight all the addictions there's
not one addiction i don't have and every
day i fight it and i try to be you know
i try to be a good husband
a good father
a powerful example
a great [__] and to make you laugh you
know that's what i do and in other words
you know having a six inch dick you know
bragging that i have a 10 inch dick you
know i had to do other things and that's
why i created the perfect hour of sex
which is 15 15 30. 15 minutes eating ass
15 minutes licking [__] 30 minutes
[__] you can't hold your load bring a
vibrator bring a [__] vibrator and
the vibrator that i personally love is
the vibrator straight up with the mouse
on the end with the tongue you hit the
clitoris because a lot of women like
clitoris action and then you jam it
vaginally and then obviously with your
hands you string a [__] the ass and you
do what you [__] gotta do and you
know by the grace of god in my 20s my
30s my 40s my 50s i was able to come get
hard again and come again now that's not
real now 60 years old i can't jerk off
because i won't i don't have the load
like my second load now is air so why am
i gonna even do it the second time i do
it the first i go [__] hard i eat ass
i lick [__] [__]
call it a [__] day thank you lord
it's keeping you young
keeping you beautiful i mean
guys if you're watching this i know this
gentleman for 30 years he has not lost
an edge of enthusiasm
in fact you're more enthusiastic about
what you're doing and enthusiasm is
contagious that's the other thing you
taught me when you make those you know
years later i went to la and i'll never
forget i when i got to l.a in 97 the big
thing was cigars
uh demi moore smoked a cigar on a
[__] cover of a magazine and
everybody started smoking cigars so they
started these cigar telemarketing jobs
stu i was the hot i would leave at 10
i would get there at seven and leave a
[__] 10. it was it was something and
that the guy goes how did you learn how
to do this
and i couldn't explain to him what we
did i just go i just learned going from
your job to cigars is like
easter eggs
another [__] afterward that's what it
was a bigger hairier [__] [__] with
a big [__] that looks like a [__]
spider
speak to me oh toothless one you know
what i'm saying yeah i remember we uh
you know your partner took us to vegas
we go we would do the vegas trip every
year you would take them to the super
bowl the highest guys in the office your
office and the other office
kurt would take this to the to the
mirage and i remember we went to a strip
club
and we're sitting there and i'm with 14
[__] animals you know those guys i
worked here sure ray george everybody
ray george and the chicken
splits richie
and the chick kept doing splits and she
had a white a pimple on her ass a white
head
and she had a tremendous ass and i
wanted to eat her monkey but i had to
pop that white head first
that's all i wanted to do and i remember
she came over to me she goes you want to
dance i go listen i'll give you 20 to
pop that pimple on your ass yeah and
she's like get the [__] out of here and
then another girl came up and she was
dancing every time she'd split i'd go
speak to me oh toothless one and she got
up and threw me and i think george out
of the club she thought george was my
little heckling partner
but the lessons i learned in that office
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen because i got hired with your
nephew
right right i got hired with [__]
lunatic yeah and he's on the phone one
day and he's pitching and i'm around
from him and he keeps going julius
julius hold on one second julius julius
you know he's he's pitching julius
listen to me and all of a sudden kurt
walks up to me and he's helping me do a
pitch and he goes
if this [__] guy says julius one more
time i'm gonna break his [__] egg he
didn't even finish saying that and you
heard
little fire going julius he just stormed
over there give me the [__] phone he
pulled the phone from me he just hung it
up i never when we were in the back of
the voodoo lounge it was i i you know
looking back at that now i was [__] up
you know you talking about addictions i
would go in there after snorting all
night
and i would just put a tissue in my nose
just and i would call people with a
[__] tissue in my nose and then when
this one would dry out i put the tissue
in the other [__] nose we used to
work friday nights you do the show
friday at 10
or something midnight yeah and we had a
friend thursday night friday night yes
and that's how i learned how to sell
news
that's how i learned how to sell the new
ones when i was in there alone with the
incoming calls and you're really [__]
stiff at first but again
your lesson was eight to be enthusiastic
and make that guy bigger than the guy on
the phone what the [__] are you i never
forget the first time some guy lost and
i had to go into him for like a thousand
dollars that's an education
anybody could get money from somebody
who won right try getting money from
somebody who lost and you gotta [__]
call him
bring him down to earth explain to him
that that was nothing
listen you lost ten thousand i lost
thirty thousand what are you [__]
crying about i lost thirty thousand i
can't even come up with the thirty two
to get the kilo of coke from the
colombian that's coming at three o'clock
and you're crying on me about your
[__] 500. grab your [__] wife's
[__] tell her we're going 2-0 tonight
and you just [__] spiel and you just
blow up and if you look at my videos
that's what i do
if you look at my videos i'm doing what
i would do on the phone
only in a video and you get enthusiastic
as you're pitching and the more more you
get up the sale is eminent
the sale is right there you you you
don't even have to sell them the
enthusiasm [__] sells them the same
thing i did on stage so
i think you should rewrite the book and
put it out there for sale like gene
paret and judy carter call it how to
[__] influence people and get your
dick sucked
i like it and make money while you're
doing it
ready to roll that's [__] awesome
i'll do it let's go that's the book you
gotta write all right i can do that
tired when you're sick and you want to
just hang at home
what you have in your head
can help [__] corporations they don't
even know how to train people you call
these people
you call these [__] people they said
you hold on hold until we [__] get to
you your business is appreciated you
would never do that
no you would be on that you'd have 20
phones around you [__] you
i got 2-0 hold on i got a thousand you
don't even give a [__] so now
what you're doing is [__] i miss i was
thinking about selling again on the
phone like i don't want to do comedy
but i was thinking about you and i'm
like oh my god i would do that for five
[__] years but there's no business
doing that anymore everything's on the
internet like you said right right
everything's on the internet now you
know now you don't speak to anyone i
don't speak to anybody i literally do
not speak to what i haven't spoke to a
customer probably in five years like not
a word it's via text because now they
they just want the games they don't want
the story they don't want to hear
nothing they just text it to me
good to go love you watch your videos
you make us laugh every morning your
motivation in the morning your food
throughout the day
your craziness we live vicarious through
you still we don't want we know
everything about you there's nothing you
can tell us about you we don't want to
hear nothing just and what i do now joe
is it's a simple price it's one price
for everyone there is no reorder there
is no bump there is no special games
there is no pie in the sky it is what it
is whether you bet a hundred million a
game or a dollar a game you're getting
the exact same games which is obviously
much different than we used to run it in
the 80s and 90s so it works it it works
and now yeah they they don't go for the
sale
they you'll never get you'll never be
able to talk to someone they do not pick
up the phone as you know just like as
you and me know when when we get
hundreds of calls we don't know the
person it's going to voicemail we're
never speaking to someone forever unless
we know the person and truth be told we
don't speak to anybody anymore i i text
i text i really don't have time to talk
to people like this like that's why it's
such a blessing to be on this podcast
with you i'm literally looking at you i
don't [__] hold you i want to get an
egg ball i want
there's no stopping us i think listen
let's do one
let's do one last comedy tour you and me
joey and stu [__] the world eat our ass
let's [__] come i think that's what
should be it that should be
i'm not even ready let's [__] come
we'll smoke blunts with everybody in the
[__] crowd we'll get a place where
it's legal everybody has to be over 21
we just get [__] up hug it out laugh
get [__] naked and let's [__] go
let's do it no i mean every listen every
time i see people in the street they're
like stu can you [__] my wife stu my
wife loves you i never ate a [__] in my
life i never ate her ass and i'm eating
her ass and licking her [__] only
because of you and if you want to you
can [__] my life i'm like listen i have
no prenuptials so i can't but thanks for
the thought [__] thanks for the
thought
and then when i see what the wife looks
like i'm like listen no disrespect i
would never [__] her
i couldn't get hard if you shot me with
testosterone in my penis she's a
pig a [__] pig
now still i gotta ask you something yes
because you and i are from the same cut
obviously yes with all this politically
correct [__] going on into the world
you still don't give a frenchman's [__]
you pour it on even more
absolutely no issue about it
the more the more tighter it gets i
cross the line and i smash the [__]
line and i put my ball sack on your
[__] face and i think a [__] your
wife while i'm telling you drop dead
you're a scumbag you're a [__] get a
[__] life and that's how i roll and
you either like me or hate me but i
don't [__] care because i'm me
and there is a niche that loves stew
finer there is a niche that loves my
insanity there is a niche that loves my
um
being genuine because it is what it is
you know i'm not smart enough to scam
anybody i'm not smart enough to pull the
wool over your eyes i got 550 math 390
english on my sats
the teacher called me in and said to me
are you really jewish because this might
be the lowest score any jews ever had i
said yeah i'm [__] jewish [__] you i
smoked pot since i'm seventh grade i ate
acid since i'm 10th grade eat my ass
and that's basically how it is
it's just uh i could i really
appreciate the [__] you make me laugh
more than any comic on the internet
when i wake up in the morning i go right
now
just to see what you ate for breakfast
the [__] bagels which are gorgeous
i don't know where you get this [__]
food from up there long island but i got
to come visit you pretty soon well you
said you're coming right you're going to
come here we're going to go
up there we're going to hug it out
i'll bring some reefer we'll have i'll
bring some 100 milligram edibles let's
go oh [__] you look like one of the
beatles after i get through with you i
took my brother
to awake yesterday you're not gonna
believe this i had to go to awake
and i took my brother and my brother's a
[__] boozer we're not really brothers
we just know each other since we're 10.
he's 64. okay
i pick him up at one his wife comes out
and says listen he's already tuned up
and he's asking for coke i go listen
that's not going to happen today
but i'll take i'll be with him i hadn't
seen him in 15 years we took a ride
still the whole way up it was gibberish
and then we got the rudy's and he
[__] ate we ate and he had eight
beers in 45 minutes
and three shots of whatever the [__] and
then he got a double espresso and he got
two shots of 43 in there
okay and then we went to the wake and on
the way to the wake he's talking about
hookers and [__] people up the ass
and i go listen knock it off i go you
want to do an edible
he goes [__] that that that don't do
nothing to me and all this [__] i go
listen all i got is a 2 i had 225s and a
130 the bartender gave it to me he
didn't see that so i just ripped the
130. he goes what's this a 25 i go it's
a 12 and a half
so i gave him the 60 milligrams by the
time we got to the 34
he was sweating [__] profusiously in
the car he took the water he opened it
up still and he just poured it on his
head
i was [__] dying and he threw the
bottle in the back and he's in the car
he's like i can't even think these
edibles what did you give me
and i go don't worry about nothing he
[__] went home he called me at nine
he was still [__] up then he called me
this morning at nine in the morning to
tell me he didn't sleep from the [__]
edible but when he poured that water on
his [__] head
like there's only three people that
haven't changed in 30 years you me
and him
so funny you know what it is when people
smoke pot and they think they can smoke
pot you know they're not in our league
when people do edibles i could do a
thousand milligrams of edibles and you
would all i do is eat faster that's
[__] it nothing you can't even tell
i'm off base case in point dave portnoy
that we do the boston sports advisor
[__] my boss okay i give him
six punch bars 250 milligrams each
tremendous so i tell him him and his
sylvanas he's got this drop dead
gorgeous woman he's with right now what
a [__] sweetheart she's a 10. i pray
to god he marries her you know he says
he doesn't know i'm like let's plan the
wedding let's play in the bartle shower
name your [__] kids me let's go stews
boys girls anyway so i give him six
punch balls i tell him to eat the whole
punch bar and his girl to eat the whole
punch bar p.s he eats thanksgiving
morning 160 milligrams to show you what
a lightweight he is and a lightweight a
lot of people are yeah it takes time
he goes to his parents house in
massachusetts
he has a bad reaction they take him to
the [__] hospital
thanksgiving he's in the [__]
hospital on 160 milligrams of a [__]
edible i'm like so p.s i felt a little
guilty i said you're [__] a [__] as
far as eating edibles you know like he's
not a [__] by any means he's got a
quarter of a billion bucks his dick is
this big he [__] like a porn star and
he lives like a rock star there's no way
sure about that but
on the tv show
to show him he's a [__] i take 250
milligrams right and [__] in front of
him i'm like are you crazy p.s went back
you know because you're allowed to smoke
there went on the deck smoked three four
more blondes i'm like dave i feel great
what's going on he goes i don't know i
guess i'm never gonna doubt you again i
go [__] hey you ain't gonna doubt me
it's one thing i could do i could [__] i
make you laugh i can eat and i could do
[__] edibles until i'm blue in the
face no anyways about punch bars i
haven't seen those in three years oh
they were amazing
my buddy gave them to me but my buddy
gave them to me i think he was he was i
think he was either in california or
arizona they brought them back to me i
saw them i used to get those they have
dark chocolate milk juice that's what no
right exactly tremendous those things
the best the best the best but i like
chocolate edibles i like the chocolate
edibles with the mushroom powder in them
too oh i can get you those little
mushroom in that [__]
100 milligram edible it puts you you
know it makes a basketball game look
completely [__] different you
understand me now i don't understand
what is your sports doing now you still
i'm kicking tremendously
i'm killing because listen
i have done this for 42 years right now
the world's on my dick because literally
i'm not bragging there is no one on this
[__] earth that knows sports gambling
more than me i've done it it's the only
job i've ever done in my entire [__]
life so i've seen it all i've done it
all i've made millions and i've lost
much more than i've made because that's
reality gambling is for the rich to have
fun and lose money but now where it is
is i'd like to teach people to go
against the grain against the public
whatever i tell people when you gamble
let's say you're gambling on your own
whatever you like bet the other side do
you think you jerk off can beat the
oddsmaker do you think there's [__]
casinos and everybody can bet legally
because you don't [__] know what you're
doing no be a [__] man be a woman and
whatever you like go the other way
because you're a sucker and if you don't
know you're a sucker i'm telling you
you're a sucker so now you know you're a
[__] sucker so i'm trying to teach
people first of all gambling is like
going to a show it's for entertainment
these people think they're going to
gamble and get rich buy a house buy a
car buy a business no that's not how it
works
you
gamble because it's for the rich because
they love the entertainment they love
the knot in their stomach because rich
people are very competitive and they
can't beat gambling so all they do is
try to beat something that they can't
hang their head against the [__] wall
lose all their [__] money then they
come to me and i give them an education
first of all
limited games you got to bet a week
people don't want to hear that people
want to bet 5 10 games a day i'm like
listen my i sell games every day but my
top top people my people at that real
money that won two games a week max
maybe they don't even bet during a week
because that's how you make money you
can't bet every day you grind it out you
get [__] killed and now that
everybody could gamble even the youth of
america it's dangerous because people
here's how it works joe people that are
betting 100 a game
should be betting 10 a game people that
are betting a thousand should be betting
a hundred people are betting ten
thousand should be betting a thousand
people that are betting a hundred
thousand should be betting ten thousand
they don't wanna hear that they don't
wanna hear that so when i tell them
reality they don't want reality they
want to live in the fantasy they want to
live and hey i'm going to be the first
[__] person to win you know if you
hit
58 of your bets you are the best in the
world if you hit 60 61.62 that's a
career year you could never do that
overall because that's just not doable
but these people hit 20 on their own 10
how about never win people come to me
stu i'm stuck 40 000 can you get me out
um how much you're betting a game 300 uh
no
you're never getting out you [__]
jerk off forget about the past
don't chase your losses
learn what gambling is gamble every day
but put it in perspective you have to
have discipline and listen as you know
as i know the way we learn the hard
lesson is we crush ourselves we're
[__] down we're gutted drunks where
[__] our faces are in the puke and
that's how we learn you know we're
[__] hard-headed guys you and me you
know that we have no fear there's
nothing we can't overcome the more you
tell us we can't do it we're gonna
[__] say [__] [__] you i'm the [__]
your mother i'm gonna [__] your daughter
and then i'm gonna [__] own you you
[__] get on your [__] shine box but
the reality is
that
gambling has to be put in his right
perspective but your first question i'm
off the wall i'm bigger than u.s steel
i'm [__] i don't even know what to do
with the [__] money that's how big i
am and because i'm honest in what i do
you know you pay me just like i said the
guy that bets ten dollars a game or the
guy that's a million again he's getting
my best of my best of my best and that's
really how i run every day i have one
game i absolutely love and then the rest
is for fun and that's how we do it now
so let's say i give five games uh like i
have seven games tonight people are
gonna bet all seven for the same amount
of money i literally tell them lists in
that this one for for the max and the
rest for fun they don't [__] listen
to me they don't care they're just
firing because they're trying to either
be me
bet over their heads or make up for past
mistakes where you know it
we you can never make up for past
mistakes it has to be clean slate deep
breath and do the best you can today the
past doesn't matter the [__] future
doesn't matter you live in the [__]
present you give a hundred percent and
you roll from there but you know
gambling is bigger than ever now it's
becoming illegal everywhere and uh you
know it's uh you know it's in my real
house you know these shout outs are in
my wheelhouse comedies in my wheelhouse
motivations in my wheelhouse telling
people that i failed and i failed and i
failed and failure after failure you
don't lose your enthusiasm for four
years where i was on the balls of my ass
i didn't pay my mortgage for four years
i couldn't [__] afford bread
i survived and then i thought i had it
together and i fell another three years
and i just grinded it out i thought my
life was over i kept praying i was in a
depression and i finally just blew it
out i persevered the cream always rises
to the top i have a skill set with you
know being funny having energy and being
gut level honest i i don't mind telling
you
i failed i'm a glorious failure in the
eyes of god that's okay but i never ever
ever [__] stopped and that's the
[__] bottom line so you know failure
is part of life everyone fails matter of
fact most people fail a lot but you just
grind it out you go forward you have
confidence you have confidence in
yourself that's the key like people want
to say that other people help them and
without you i wouldn't be here without
this and that but truth be told it's you
you have to love yourself self-love in
my in my experience and in my opinion
right now is the thing that the world is
lacking people don't love themselves
people want to focus on what they don't
have what they can't do what they wish
they could do instead of what you have
you're a beautiful loving person you're
a child of god
and every person brings their unique
substance to the world and we need that
and we really [__] need it but now
everybody's so insecure you know so
inadequate so scared people scared to
make a mistake [__] that make mistakes
[__] fail you only learn from failure
nobody's ever learned from success no
one has ever [__] learned from
success in their entire [__]
life you learn from failure you learn
what you do wrong and god willing you
don't repeat your mistakes so that you
know that's really what i'm rolling with
right now joe i'm thinking about what
you said that this has been your life
and just just let people know how deep
your jimmy runs
the first three days of training
they talk about the mind of the gambler
and the waves how it goes up in the
psychology i still remember learning
that
we did we learned that way before we
talked about five times or ten times or
the pitch
we talked about how to catch em how they
go up and down they're like manic
depressants and you gotta get them
somewhere in the middle i i learned
you know the first ten times you call
somebody they tell you to go [__]
yourselves
and then you taught us to say whoa whoa
before you hang up on me i know i'm a
loser tell me who you gambling with
tonight who you betting
and i'll tell you if you're in the right
direction and then you go listen one of
your sides is opposite me
this was my [__] life it was called
the fifty thousand dollar objection to
[__] tremendous yeah i used it in
this way when i would do a showcase when
i first got to l.a and stu would say
i'll be there tonight and then stu
wouldn't show up i'd call you the next
day
and i'd go stew you [__] up why i had
the set of my life rodney dangerfield
was there doing coke lindsay lohan was
sucking dick and you're at home because
you didn't want to come see me this
wasn't about coming to see me this is
about the whole and then they go okay
i'll come next time i would just make up
lies tell them lindsay lohan was there
sucking [__] jenna jameson was at the
comedy store
to let them know what they missed and
the other thing that i have to go with
you is your honesty
i spoke to people over the years in
california that they also had worked for
a sports cat betting service
you guys were not doing what these
people are doing
these people were giving sides to one
guy's side of it
guys would pick three picks and break
them up to people to try to teach them
our first rule was to slow them the [__]
down
and then you own them and it's
even your gambling lesson i started
gambling last year on draftkings i love
draftkings they're my sponsor
i bet 25 a game
good exactly sunday is my best day
that basketball that's the quickest way
to commit suicide it's every [__] day
if i see something outrageous on a
monday night you know the knicks break
break my [__] heart brooklyn breaks
my heart on a constant level uh utah
comes true for me in hoops chicago bulls
they're playing tonight
and uh
you know golden states they didn't cover
last night those [__] i don't
know if they did no no phoenix i had
phoenix last night that was my
game of the [__] basketball week
there was no thursday night
[__] football this week so
and even myself it's 25
and you're smart exactly because you've
learned you learn you know it you're not
gonna win
no if you start thinking you're not
gonna win i do it to watch the game i
haven't listened stu i got into comedy
in 91
i was with your company till 95
i was with you guys when i got the call
to go on the road
and i had to go to curt and say listen
i'm going on the road blah blah blah
and the rest i went to seattle but i
always used
your little [__] techniques like that
clothes you thought i forgot about that
that's the n word to the and then
they'll call you three days from that
they'll call you three days and then go
hey man you were right i had a game
opposite yours come on let's go grab the
[__] card tell your wife your [__]
hairs are gonna stand on fire i'll never
forget when we used to work friday
nights it was a smaller crew so you
could work more with kurt kurt would
work more with you
the [__] he would say to people
you know he would always go
watch my lips you know and he would
pitch you
and there was stuff i had a hard time
saying at first and he would get mad at
me but when i started saying those
things i started selling
as soon as i started reading his lips
watch and then he'd get on the phone and
yell and give you the phone back people
didn't have a [__] idea what was
going on you always ran
a very legit service i really enjoyed i
didn't feel like i was doing anything
wrong when i was there i was working at
a car wash when richie discovered me
i had just come out of prison
i was in the halfway house and i was
working as a host at the puddle car wash
in boulder right down the block from the
office and richie
rizzo
george they would all come in i go how
do you guys get nice cars i thought they
were drug dealers
and then they started talking a little
bit about sports and i thought they were
[__] uh
bookies i go here i left [__] jersey
and i'm surrounded by bookies in boulder
and then finally in 93
they came to me and they go if you want
a job go over there and talk to them two
week training
bagels on sunday flown out courtesy of
stew [__] cream cheese from long
island it was just
it was a dream come true for me and you
had no idea what i i was going through
my divorce at that time
i was in court every other week i lost
the child the 32 year old my daughter
does not talk to me till today
and uh you know stu uh kirk got me an
attorney you know he gave me his
attorney and we never got anywhere but i
was going through a heavy [__] period
when i was there i was living by myself
the cocaine i had a guy that even if i
owe him 2000 he'd bring me an eight ball
he's the best guy in the world i owed
him fifteen hundred dollars for twelve
years
i went to denver to do the comedy works
i called him and i ended up giving him
two grand for what he had done for me i
could have just beat him but he was such
a great guy vince he would deliver right
to the office
that office people have no idea how much
fun it was
working for you i remember one day it
was laid down stairs that cut hair and
she used to always tell me i'm going to
suck your dick and i'm like no you're
not she was hot
and one day she broke her leg skiing and
she was down and i'm like hey i'm in the
mood for a [__] today she walked me
outside with a cast got on one knee and
had the cast stretched out and tsuka la
mink i went upstairs it was [__]
tremendous is true remember there was a
haircut in place downstairs yeah
remember when they moved into the bigger
office yes
and then in la
i went to a lady's house one night my
wife my daughter was born and she
started going to school
and she became friends with my wife
somehow and i went over there one day
and the lady said to me
you don't recognize me
i don't know
she goes i'm jen i was the bartender at
murphy's
when you worked for curtin you guys will
always come downstairs to murphy's and
eat
so i always get
i there's not one day i don't think
about what i learned with you
there's not one day that's awesome
that's good to hear that's guys here
i've heard a ton of stories like that
because because look
it lasts forever because it's a great
skill set builds confidence builds
energy and it works you know it works
there's no you know it's no two ways
about it you you know we really i really
always taught people how to be actors
you know how to be like professional
actors confidence flows through your
body through the phone and you're ready
to roll and you know just like you said
i'm grateful that you said that because
you know we never double-sided games we
always gave one game we died by it we
never booked make we never tried to
catch up with a [__] bookmaker we did
the best we can
live or die and that's how we rolled you
know we were fun and aggressive on the
phones but like you said no guilt
because it was [__] straight up
honesty we did what we had to do and it
was what it was and like you said these
people in cali and these other people
they're [__] thieves i mean you know
they're they're literal they should be
in jail i mean it's not israel and i'm
never judging a neighbor i don't want to
put anybody in jail because you know my
house you know i you know i don't want
to throw stones i have a glass house
i've done it all you know like this you
know this [__] you and me have done
we're never telling anyone it's never
happening we're going to die going
through our graves today you know
because like you said we're glorious
values we've done some [__] but pretty
much like you put your head on the
pillow you can go to sleep same with me
always i always use my real name i
always you know represented myself and
that's the [__] bottom line so uh you
know like both of us said we got we got
nothing to look back on but good things
and the future looks great for both of
us the smartest thing you did
saying that because a lot of people are
not going to understand
what you said to people to be an actor
and i'm going to break it down for them
you gave us a name
for me it was pistol pete
so when i called people i wasn't joey
diaz i wasn't coco diaz i wasn't a [__]
i was
pistol pete
pistol pete snorted
he drank booze he had vd he got
gonorrhea he got his dick sucked
he smacked people he went to jail for
[__] what you know that's who pistol
p was so when you went into that office
you left joey diaz behind it was that's
why i said to you before when kurt would
speak to you
you had to learn how to now this helped
me with stand up stu
you had to learn how to say what he was
saying
i had to learn what he was saying
so when you're saying those things at
first they're like oh my god i can't
believe i'm telling this guy to tell his
wife to shave the [__] that we got
three winners today you know
that helped me later on with comedy then
i became joey offstage
and coco on stage the one who talked
about pulling the tampon out of your
[__] or lighting it on fire when i was
eating your [__] you ever do that
you're eating ass and they got the
period and you pull the string back and
forth they go [__] bananas and then
you whip it out when they come and you
eat that [__] thing and then it
[__] explodes it's like a tickle with
blood on it who gives a [__] we've eaten
everything we swam in the hudson
true i listen i eat ass in the whole
house so i can't say that
i'm not opposed not opposed did you eat
ass at the 10 40 club
um
how did you know how did you know about
the 10 40 i went there when i was the
most hot it was the worst night of my
life
i've never felt so embarrassed it
scarred me so much i've never been with
a hooker the rest of my [__] life hey
i ended up over there with a kid papa
pedro
oprah gun
pedro or begun and i didn't know what
was going on often you paid
the 10 40. they gave you a little ticket
you went inside a little bell came out
like the bagels are ready you ever see
those jewish delis they have the red
light the bagels already and also they
pushed out a bunch of russian and dirty
white chicks they were crying you had to
tackle them and then you gave the guy a
sticker and he put you into the back
into an office space you could hear
other people moaning and groaning you
could smear that you could smell the
strippers feets and their [__] and
then i'll never forget the chick [__]
wash your dick with a bucket
it looked like rocky spittoon the one he
spit in that foam and [__]
she would clean your helmet
and then tell you what you wanted around
the world
a half and a half or a straight [__] and
i go let's do a half and half and she's
on me bouncing and i'm dying inside i
can hit my dick going quack quack
dirty snatch and all of a sudden she
stops doing she goes you know for an
extra 10 you could eat my [__] i put my
two hands under her thighs and i just
threw her off i'll never forget she had
holes in the stockings
that killed me killed me this dude who
the [__] [__] a lady with holes in the
stocking
her heel was sticking out her little toe
was sticking out it was brown
pimper stepped on a foot 2 000 [__]
times
stu when can i come over and see you
brother
yesterday
okay i'm going to give you a call next
week and set something up and i can come
over 100 and see you we'll come over and
see you over at the sports when the
[__] building opens up because
nobody's seen nobody because of covet
stew i love you i love you all my heart
thank you for not forgetting me i never
forgot you and i never forgot you i love
you it means a lot thank you so so much
you're very kind and uh whenever i saw
your nephew i always asked him about you
you know i love that [__] he
made me laugh
cousin
deli people have no idea i got another
hour of stories from that [__] deli
when there'd be 20 people in the [__]
place waiting for a sandwich and they'd
bust out into a fistfight
they do that in boulder not new york new
york people look at they were having a
fist fight behind the counter people
were waiting for their chicken cutlet
[__] sandwich uh that's my father's
brother's kid
[__] amazing i love this dude i love
you joe thank you so much i'm putting
this on monday morning [__] these
[__] [__] go let's [__]
go
anything you want to say before we leave
any way they get a hold of you um yeah i
mean always you could pull me up at
stuffiner.com
and then uh for any shout outs or
merchandise that belikestew.com
and then uh just watch our show on
barcelo sports advisors and you can find
that you know always on the internet i'm
all i'm everywhere and then uh let's
[__] go let's have some fun when is
the show gone what nights um friday
night at seven o'clock so tonight at
seven correct okay i love you stu god
bless you happy birthday
and thank you for coming on the joint
we'll be in touch tarzan okay god bless
you love you love you
oh
thank you i hope you enjoyed [__]
uncle stu it was a great chat that was
part one we're gonna have a part two
pretty soon about a month or so i'll get
him back on i'm gonna try to do
something with him go up to long island
yell and scream maybe for the super bowl
go up there we'll make some [__]
videos and blow your goddamn minds guys
again
i'm sorry about last week we are gonna
[__] turn this [__] around
you guys know me dawg i'm a [__]
savage it takes time
uh we're gonna turn this [__] around i
think i'm getting rid of the [__]
couch i'm doing a bunch of different
changes it's gonna take a while but i
feel better i'm more confident and i
hope you guys enjoyed today's [__]
podcast with my main man stu
[__] fighter
uh we'll be back wednesday
patreon's kicking everybody's on [__]
fire and we're ready to go it's a cold
[__] today here in jersey on a
monday morning i gotta go for a [__]
knee this morning to check out both
knees i got jiu jitsu i got a great
[__] day i love you [__] with
all my heart have a great monday and
don't forget alabama georgia tonight
draftkings got suckers stay black and
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
all right you [__] savages i want to
thank my main man stu finally visit him
go see stew get the deal
he's great and he knows exactly what
he's doing and he'll make it right for
you he'll put you back on the winning
track speaking about winning track
i'm showing up with draftkings you
understand me the nfl playoffs are here
starting next week the wild card weekend
tonight we got a great game alabama
georgia this is your time but for the
super bowl we're doing something
sensational for the for the wild card is
what i mean you bet five dollars and you
win 280 and free bets if your team is
victorious that's what draftkings is
doing for you right now the sports book
isn't available in your state yet never
fear uncle joe is here we got something
to play with for wild card weekend
everyone can play for huge cash prizes
with draftkings daily fantasy football
contest draftkings has given all new
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars in total prizes with their first
deposit so do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app now or
the fantasy app the sports book you put
you're gonna get 56 to one eyes on any
nfl team
five dollars will make you 280 and free
bets that's how uncle joey shows up on a
[__] monday that's promo code joey
this wild card weekend a draftking
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana pa
i see new yorkers doing it now
congratulations new customers only file
deposit dollar wager required one per
customer restrictions do apply okay
don't be greedy see draftkings.com sport
book for details now if you've got a
gammon prom call 1-800 gamble but if not
head over to draftkings let's get this
party
started the joint is also brought to you
by my personal favorite
cbd lion from the kinesiology tape
to the
cream
to the the hemp weed they have that's
coming out with a new line i hope i i'm
trying to check it out with them but the
capsules the cbd capsules tremendous if
you don't want to do the tension they
got the bath balls i mean listen cbd
line i've been with them this is going
to be my fourth year and i still use
them you see the products keep
disappearing that's
cbdlion.com go read the third-party lab
results
and get some tincture to get your year
started relax sleep better
eat better it's your year cbd line i
want to thank cbd lion
draftkings but most importantly i want
to thank you [__]
for having my back with the joint do not
forget laughing gas is available at ice
cream shop
i love you [__] with all my
heart have a great day have a great week
and i'll see you guys wednesday the 10th
tip
no wednesday the 12th tip
top magoo love you [__]
[Music]
foreign
you